ciao a tutti
di solito stories una vita e oggi nuova
challenge s'indovina se acqua o slice vi
ricordate le ho già forte un sacco di
tempo fa ora abbiamo nuovi video in cui
c'è anche vitale vediamo chi riesce a
qualche punto dovrete indovinare se a
foz lime prima che ci immergono le mani
dentro e dovete insegnarvi quanti punti
avete fatto la fine del video commentate
nei commenti quanti punti avete fatto
vediamo se vediamo se avremmo fatto più
punti noi e voi se prodi mettetevi
comodi pop cordoba è il mio primo slide
out of time cioè ho detto prima slime ma
potrebbe essere al bianco arbus life air
race live
secondo me acqua vediamo quando accusa è
strano questo e tutto intorno forse qua
tipo una piscinetta e poi c'è un pezzo
qua boh non capisco come ho fatto io
dico sly l'antico slide vediamo nessuna
carta sotto erto perché
la carta foto per leggere pensavo fosse
sopra siamo 1 a 0 numero aprea con slime
io dico che slime io dico acqua mi
sembra troppo trasparente vediamo ora
numero 4 a cowes lime
secondo me slime sì forse queste prime
non lo so se vediamo un dico slime line
auguro io super trasparente quindi siamo
dalle 20 bello bellissimo numero 5
difficile questo
questo potrebbe essere acqua però io
dico slime io dico acqua vediamo
tre a due il numero 6 si accusa in ballo
secondo me questa volta questa è acqua
sì anche secondo me non mi freghi perché
qua ha lasciato tutto il residuo
dell'acqua insomma stesso però direi
acqua ma anch'io non aspetta a meno che
non ne slime intorno con l'acqua in
centro vabbè diciamo acquaviva acqua
credere quindi rimaniamo tre a due il
numero
io per sempre il corso
allora saremo acqua sembra slime così
dire slime in questo caso vediamo
[Musica]
sì quindi quattro a tre lettere questo
direi acqua mi sembra troppo trasparente
medico apcom io dico slime invece
intendiamo quindi 52 breve debitori
laimo acqua
allora questa sembra acqua a me sembra
sliven invece qua per voi cosa dite
dolci questo bordello quindi meritato di
più di claire t allora slime online
questo s line
sì mi sa che flame voi che dite scrivete
nei commenti
ciao fregato oddio ho bloccato giusto in
tempo slime o acqua sliven city e milan
impediamo si rispetti a 447 look
l'estremo acqua acqua rich acqua sì sì
anch'io dico acqua vediamo troppo
trasparenti slam o acqua non si capisce
niente ma in realtà mi sembra troppo
trasparente
credo sia acqua io dico acqua acqua sì
anche perché si vede la gocciolina lì
sul bordo ok acqua ridiamo acqua eh sì
finalmente abbiamo beccato un altra nota
gico e lime o acqua mi sembra stu lime
perché deve un po opaco vedi pure sul
bordo si nota
io dico acqua non dallo sfondo come
riflette potreste la ragione però non mi
fido dico slime vediamo laimo acqua
acqua si vede subito che acqua questa a
ieri con slide e voi cosa dite
[Musica]
se non mi riconosco quanti pur dei
abbiamo fatta 86 96 96 ua questa enorme
no questa sarà l'acqua per forza o forse
sì perché vedi sul bordo si vedono delle
bollicine non lo so veramente difficile
questo è il succo e trasparente scrivete
quelli come te drive o acqua
io dico acqua io dico slime 20 a lime o
acqua questa slime si vede sì anche se
quando non è questo blind people who
segmenti tutte le volte che mi pare dice
si vede che cosa un posto è vero
scrivetemi come di sligo acqua prendiamo
questo slime sicuro ma l'ha cambiato nel
frattempo ma ha infatti sembrava un po
diverso però era slime comunque abbiamo
indovinato slime o acqua può dire che
questo sembra proprio acqua in un
bicchiere
vediamo se ci sorprende
non ci posso credere però fatto bene è
perfetto
incredibile slime ormai non mi fido più
verso line
io dico acqua voi cosa dite presente
slime slime come palm parli così ben
parenti questo così come secondo voi il
traino acqua io dico acqua
sì anche dico acqua mi sembra un po di
acqua in un secchio esatto anche perché
si vede dalle gocciolino dell'acqua sul
sul bordo e diamo si altro che i the oc
e lime o acqua e dico sliven questa
volta io dico up
vediamo era uno strale devo dire che era
perfetto
perfetti io però ho indovinato io brava
a meno acqua io dico acqua
non lo so perché difficili voi preferite
slam o acqua acqua
vediamo bene sì tra acqua non ci credo
ma non è possibile dare a questa è acqua
sicuro deve essere acqua per forza basta
infatti questo è per forza acqua dai non
è possibile
scrivete voi nei commenti
no non ci posso credere che così bello
non capisco adesso un po trasparente
incredibile drymonakos slime è ormai
slime perché totalmente perfetti gli
direi io non slide effettivamente questo
potrebbe essere un host line con il
bordeaux fly mousseline mediamo perché
se questo la pira qua ci rimanevano
troppo vale aimo ha un colore un po più
ma secondo me l'hanno fatto apposta per
ingannarci questo io dico acqua a piedi
con slime perché forse la colla un po
giallina vediamo della colla si sa mai
non si mandano la stessa vediamo se è
bello però questo pure io vorrei toccare
non si capisce niente qua io credo sia
slime questo io dico acqua dice vediamo
del reparto ha fatto che finanziò male
allora questo
se dico anch'io slam voi che dite laimo
atto e siamo quasi alla fine slime io
dico slime pure se ci sono dei grassi
abbiamo decisamente fifa in poi è stato
non è stato bravo perché dovevo
aspettare che le ssis chiarissero quindi
slime si disse sì sì sì sì sì in effetti
sì sembra troppo trasparente di reja che
vediamo aspetta si è scritto pensavo
veramente che questo fosse slime pesce
d'aprile
da oggi siamo che l'acqua sembra slime
credo proprio che dico acqua si guarda
sul bordo le goccioline d'acqua
invitiamo però devi cambiare allora
abbiamo sbagliato
un sacco di rumore scrivete nei commenti
quanti punti avete foto non si
ricordiamo per niente quanti punti forti
ci ho perso quando pensi di aver vinto
io non si ritrovano quando io guardo io
stavo a sei tu stavi già 9 10 lasciate
un bel haj che fate sapere che altre
challenge volete vedere sul canale ora
vi lascio con quattro passeggeri
spiccare per vedere le nostre under
challenge nostri altri video divertenti
cliccate su quello che preferite
ciao